This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in 2008, I started listening to a podcast called The Memory Palace by my friend Nate DeMeo. It's a history show, and it was unlike anything I'd ever heard before. Each episode wrapped a little-known piece of history inside one of Nate's poetic essays. His stories have an uncanny ability to weave together facts and insight to help us imagine the real lives of historical figures and to call to mind forgotten moments from the past.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。早在2008年，我开始收听我朋友内特·德梅奥制作的播客《记忆宫殿》（The Memory Palace）。这是一档历史类节目，它与我之前听过的任何节目都截然不同。每一集都将一段鲜为人知的历史包裹在内特富有诗意的散文中。他的故事有一种不可思议的能力，能将事实与洞察力交织在一起，帮助我们想象历史人物的真实生活，并唤起我们对过去被遗忘时刻的记忆。
In fact, The Memory Palace is one of the early inspirations for 99% Invisible, and now, after 15 plus years of making his podcast, Nate has a new book out called, you guessed it, The Memory Palace. It's an anthology of some of his best stories from the show, plus a few new ones. We're gonna play two of those stories in a little bit, but first I talk with Nate about making his podcasts and writing his book.
事实上，《记忆宫殿》是《99% Invisible》早期的灵感来源之一。如今，在制作播客15年多之后，内特推出了一本新书，正如你所猜到的，书名就叫《记忆宫殿》。这是一部选集，收录了他节目中一些最精彩的故事，还有几篇全新的作品。稍后我们将播放其中两个故事，但首先，我将与内特聊聊他制作播客和撰写这本书的过程。
So you open the book with this line, something moved me once, and then you go on to describe all the ways that little bits of information have cut through the deluge of media that we're bombarded with every day. Why did you open the book this way? I think that that first line that you read, that something moved me once, I trust the being moved.
你用“曾经有什么东西触动了我”这句话作为开篇，接着你描述了各种各样的小信息是如何穿透我们每天被轰炸的媒体洪流的。你为什么以这种方式开篇？我认为你读到的那第一行字，“曾经有什么东西触动了我”，我信任那种被触动的感觉。
It's fundamental to what I do with the Memory Palace, but I think it's also fundamental of the way that I am. I think that at some point as a younger person, I really became fascinated with the question of why do I remember this thing? Like why out of all the days of one summer in 1989 when I was a young kid, is this the trip to the ice cream store that I remember?
这对我用《记忆宫殿》所做的事情至关重要，但我认为这也是我为人处世的根本。我想在年轻时的某个时刻，我真的对“为什么我会记得这件事”这个问题着了迷。比如，在1989年那个夏天的所有日子里，为什么我偏偏记得去冰淇淋店的那次旅行？
And some of that is just this simple and to me kind of like lovely notion of we only remember memorable lovely notion of we only remember memorable things. Like we only remember the thing that kind of like snaps us out of our just sort of like normal day to day experience and grabs our attention. And so the question that I sort of asked myself over and over again when I'm writing these stories, but also just in my life in general is like, why was this the thing that caught
其中一部分原因就是这个简单且对我而言非常美好的概念：我们只记得值得记忆的事物。就像我们只记得那些让我们从日常生活中跳脱出来、抓住我们注意力的事情。所以，我在写这些故事时，以及在生活中，不断问自己的问题是：为什么偏偏是这件事吸引了我的目光？
my eye? these stories, but also just in my life in general is like, why was this the thing that caught my eye? And I'm fascinated to try to figure out why, and then to also try to like, share that wonder that you experience when you learn that incredible fact about the past or that incredible turning point, or just like simply really connected with a story of, living in another time that you will never meet and then trying to find a way to share not just that story but share that feeling that I felt, try to find a way to put it all together and share it with the listener. And so knowing that the Memory Palace is designed perfectly to deliver the type of thing you want in a podcast, when you were translating this to turn it into
我着迷于找出原因，同时也试图分享那种当你了解到关于过去的惊人事实，或那个不可思议的转折点时所体验到的惊奇感，或者仅仅是与一个你永远无法相见、生活在另一个时代的人的故事产生了共鸣。我试图找到一种方法，不仅分享那个故事，还要分享我所感受到的那种感觉，试图找到一种方法将这一切整合起来并分享给听众。既然知道《记忆宫殿》被设计得非常适合以播客形式呈现，那么当你将其转化为《记忆宫殿》这本书时，你还在权衡和思考哪些其他因素？你在运用哪些手段？在思考播客时，我一直在考虑形式，你知道，播客与广播的不同之处。所以，去思考这本书，去思考当这些熟悉的故事被写在纸上时会发生什么，是一件令人兴奋的事情。
Memory Palace, the book, what were some of the other considerations you were sort of juggling and thinking about and what levers were you pulling? In thinking about the podcast, I think about format all the time, you know, the ways that the podcast is different than radio. And so it was exciting to then go and think about the book and think about what happens to some of these familiar
（续上）在思考播客时，我一直在考虑形式，你知道，播客与广播的不同之处。所以，去思考这本书，去思考当这些熟悉的故事被写在纸上时会发生什么，是一件令人兴奋的事情。
stories when they get put down on the page. Some of it was like, does this story hold up on the page? Is there something that only works because of the way the music works? Or is there something that only works because of the way that I am able to have total control of the way that this is paced because I'm going to say these words when I want to say them. And so, you know, part of the excitement was to try to figure out, like, how through prose I could, you know, try to replicate some of those things. And so some of it was the kind of, like, delight of doing that. But the other thing was I also realized that there was a number of different types of stories that I could tell that I just can't tell, which is things that require you to look at
有些故事是这样的：这个故事在纸上站得住脚吗？是否有某些东西仅仅因为音乐的运用才奏效？或者是否有某些东西仅仅因为我能完全掌控节奏才奏效，因为我会在我想说的时候说出这些词。所以，你知道，兴奋的一部分在于试图弄清楚，我如何通过散文来复制那些东西。所以其中一部分是这样做的乐趣。但另一件事是，我也意识到我能讲的故事类型有很多，但我无法讲述那些需要你“看”的东西。
stuff. And so could you give some examples of something that you couldn't tell as a radio story that just worked really well in the book as a piece of written material? Yeah, absolutely. So stories that were about the history of photography and stories that over the course of the book explore what it is to look at photographs through time. And I come to those stories sort of in the same way, which is I just like look at stuff and wait to be moved.
那么你能举一些例子吗？比如那些你无法作为广播故事讲述，但作为书面材料却在书中表现得很好的例子？是的，绝对可以。比如关于摄影史的故事，以及在书中探讨随着时间推移观看照片意味着什么的故事。我以同样的方式接触这些故事，那就是我只是看着东西，等待被触动。
And so one day I was looking through some big tome about the history of photography. And in it, you know, while I was learning about how the daguerreotype works and all that stuff, there was like a little photograph of these three men on the roof of a building in Nashville in like 1865. And one of the guys is standing in this gigantic contraption that looks a little bit like a telescope. Then there's the thing that says, oh, this is a solar camera. I'm like, what's a solar camera?
有一天，我正在翻阅一本关于摄影史的大部头。在书中，当我了解达盖尔摄影法是如何运作以及所有这些东西时，有一张小照片，是1865年纳什维尔一栋建筑屋顶上的三个人。其中一个人站在一个看起来有点像望远镜的巨大装置里。然后旁边写着，哦，这是一个太阳照相机。我心想，什么是太阳照相机？
Oh, it's the thing that was designed to enlarge other photographs but to make them really big. I was like, wow, I've never really seen a really big photograph from the 19th century. Then the wonder comes in where I discover why, which is that none of them exist anymore. That these people built these solar cameras, that they were a big deal for about 30 years.
哦，它是用来放大其他照片，让它们变得非常大的东西。我心想，哇，我从来没见过19世纪真正的大照片。然后惊奇感就来了，我发现了原因，那就是它们现在一张都不存在了。这些人建造了这些太阳照相机，它们在大约30年的时间里非常重要。
And because of the photographic process and the paper that they had to print them on, these people made these images that themselves were often apparently not particularly precise, because as you blew them up, they start to like warp and stuff like that. But they were very popular and they were in people's homes. People would have like these life-size photographs of people they knew for a very short time and not a single one exists anymore.
由于摄影工艺和他们必须用来打印照片的纸张，这些人制作的图像本身通常并不特别精确，因为当你放大它们时，它们开始变形之类的。但它们非常受欢迎，出现在人们的家中。人们会有这些真人大小的照片，展示着他们认识的人，但时间很短，现在一张都不存在了。
And it's those sorts of things that started to like help me figure out what a memory palace story for the book could be. One of the things I love about a memory palace story is just how you capture all this humanity in the histories that you're telling. But emotions and feelings, these are the kind of details that are often absent from the historical record.
正是这些事情开始帮助我弄清楚《记忆宫殿》的故事在书中应该是什么样子。我喜欢《记忆宫殿》故事的一点是，你如何在讲述的历史中捕捉到所有这些人性。但情感和感觉，这些细节往往在历史记录中是缺失的。
So I'm curious how you think about working with that absence in your stories. Yeah, I think that what I'm really looking for are these little details that make the people that I'm reading about feel like real people. That there's something about the way that this diarist or whatever it is has said something about the dress that was worn on this particular night that like is then like, oh, you put on that dress because it's that kind of night.
所以我很好奇你是如何思考在故事中处理这种缺失的。是的，我认为我真正寻找的是那些让我在阅读时感到这些人是真实存在的细节。比如日记作者或其他什么人对那天晚上穿的衣服说了些什么，这让你觉得，哦，你穿那件衣服是因为那是那种夜晚。
I've experienced that kind of night before. I've experienced the one where you need to impress the in-laws or I've experienced the one where you need to catch that person's eye. In my own way, in my own time, I felt that and in the feeling comes the confidence that I have to use that factual thing as an anchor and then open up questions
我以前也经历过那种夜晚。我经历过那种需要给姻亲留下深刻印象的夜晚，或者我经历过那种需要吸引某人注意力的夜晚。以我自己的方式，在我自己的时代，我感受到了这一点，在这种感觉中，我有了信心，将那个事实作为锚点，然后打开问题。
because I'm never making declarative statements about like this is what this person felt. But like essentially saying like, if you were in this situation, if you were having this kind of night in this kind of dress, don't you feel like we'd feel this way? And that's where the kind of like, conjuring act, you know, when the Mary Palace is working well, like that's where it lives. It's in the idea that just like by hanging out on those specific details and calling them to mind, you're really kind of calling them to the imagination.
因为我从不发表声明说“这个人当时就是这种感觉”。而是本质上说，如果你处于这种情况，如果你穿着这种衣服度过这样的夜晚，你不觉得我们会这样想吗？这就是那种“召唤”行为，当《记忆宫殿》运作良好时，它就存在于这里。它在于这样一个想法：仅仅通过关注那些具体的细节并唤起它们，你实际上是在召唤想象力。
And you're creating this space of internal kind of emotional possibilities that I think suddenly deepens these things that otherwise might be kind of thin. So I know that in the style of the Memory Palace podcast, it is sort of anathema to describe a thing before the thing happens. But I want to play some episodes. And if you want that experience, just go subscribe to the Memory Palace, just listen to every one.
你创造了一个内在情感可能性的空间，我认为这突然加深了那些原本可能很单薄的东西。我知道在《记忆宫殿》播客的风格中，在事情发生前描述它是一种禁忌。但我想播放一些剧集。如果你想要那种体验，就去订阅《记忆宫殿》，听每一集。
You will love every single one of them. But here, I was wondering if you could help me introduce some episodes so that we can give a little bit of the behind the scenes behind certain ones. And I want to talk about Below From Above. It's a real like, 99PI. some episodes so that we can give a little bit of the behind the scenes behind certain ones. And I want to talk about Below from Above. It's a real like 99PI, like they're going to see something be built or you can experience something be built.
你会喜欢每一集的。但在这里，我想知道你是否能帮我介绍一些剧集，这样我们就能提供一些幕后花絮。我想谈谈《从上方看下方》（Below From Above）。这真的很像《99PI》，他们要看到某样东西被建造，或者你可以体验某样东西被建造的过程。
You have talked about in your notes to this episode that this was a very early inspiration from Memory Ballast, telling this story. Why was that? One of the formative inspirations for me as a thinker was definitely the Ken Burns documentary based on the book about the building of the Brooklyn Bridge. The combination of seeing that at the right time, of being kind of fascinated by the human toil and toll that its construction took, but then also being kind of like a young person, kind of like driving to New York for the first
你在这一集的笔记中提到，这是《记忆宫殿》的一个非常早期的灵感来源。为什么会这样？作为一名思考者，我早期的形成性灵感之一绝对是肯·伯恩斯关于布鲁克林大桥建造的纪录片。在正确的时间看到它，被其建造过程中人类的辛劳和代价所吸引，但同时也像一个年轻人一样，第一次开车去纽约，心想“我要走过布鲁克林大桥”。然后发现这个在城市中心感觉像中世纪的东西，并意识到它必须如此，因为那是我们当时制造东西的方式。这是我们唯一知道的方法，用石头和挖掘。
time and like being like, I'm going to walk over the Brooklyn Bridge. And then finding this thing that feels like medieval in the middle of the city and realizing that it had to be because that's how we made stuff then. It's the only way we knew how with rocks and digging. And then, you know, in walking over that bridge and realizing that like, oh, this is the tallest place on earth that wasn't like a church fire that was manmade, you know, feeling that like, holy cow, like what a thing would have been that feeling that holy cow has never left me about stories around the Brooklyn Bridge. And was one of these things
然后，你知道，走过那座桥，意识到“哦，这是地球上除了教堂尖顶之外最高的建筑，是人造的”，你知道，那种感觉就像“天哪，那该是什么样的东西啊”。那种“天哪”的感觉从未离开过我，关于布鲁克林大桥的故事。这是让我挂念的事情之一，就像“是的，总有一天我想让某人对这个特定的故事感到‘天哪’，就像我一样”。好吧，让我们听听那个故事，我们在另一边再多聊聊。如果你想建一座桥，一座横跨大片水域或相当令人印象深刻的深渊的长桥，你会想建一座悬索桥。那种两边有塔从水中或地洞中伸出来，电缆在它们之间上下起伏的桥。如果你想让桥发挥作用，承载汽车、卡车和小型货车，
that hung with me that like, yeah, someday I want to make someone feel holy cow about this particular story in the same way that I did. Okay, let's hear that story and we'll talk a little bit more about it on the other side. If you want to build a bridge, a long one over a large body of water or some reasonably impressive chasm, you'll want to build a suspension bridge. One of those with the towers on either side sticking up from the water or hole in the ground, with the cables swooping down and up and down and up between them. And if you want the bridge to work, to hold the cars and the trucks and the minivans,
（续上）如果你想让桥发挥作用，承载汽车、卡车和小型货车，
to withstand a high wind, to keep standing during an earthquake or a tsunami, those towers need to stay still so the rest of the bridge can move a little bit. It's physics, just trust me. Those towers need to be anchored deep within the ground. So you will need to dig holes, which is hard enough to do in some rocky chasm in the Pyrenees of the Poconos, but in water it's a whole other thing. So if you want to build a bridge over water, over the East River between Manhattan and Brooklyn say, and it's 1870, just you know to pick a number at random, you need to find a way to dig underwater. So fill a bathtub and take a glass and
抵御强风，在地震或海啸中保持屹立，那些塔需要保持静止，这样桥的其他部分才能稍微移动。这是物理学，相信我。那些塔需要深深地锚定在地下。所以你需要挖洞，这在比利牛斯山脉或波科诺山脉的岩石深渊中已经够难了，但在水中则是另一回事。所以如果你想在水上建一座桥，比如在曼哈顿和布鲁克林之间的东河上，现在是1870年，只是随便选个数字，你需要找到一种在水下挖掘的方法。所以装满一个浴缸，拿一个玻璃杯，
flip the glass over and push the glass to the bottom of the tub. There's air in the glass, there's water in the tub but it's water in the tub, but it can't get inside. You get it, it's a diving bell. And picture tiny people in that glass, chipping away at the porcelain or the vinyl at their feet with tiny picks and wee little shovels. Now the air will run out of that glass, so you'll need a tube or a straw poking up through the top
把玻璃杯翻过来，推到浴缸底部。玻璃杯里有空气，浴缸里有水，但水进不去。你明白了吗，这是一个潜水钟。想象一下玻璃杯里有微小的人，用微小的镐和细小的铲子在他们脚下的瓷器或乙烯基上凿开。现在玻璃杯里的空气会耗尽，所以你需要一根管子或吸管从顶部伸出来，
and up and out past the surface of the water to let the good air in and the bad air out while they tap away those tiny people with their tiny tools digging at the bottom of your tub for some reason. And that's the idea. You build a watertight chamber. You find a way to keep the air circulating within that chamber and you push it down to the bottom and you start to build your tower on top of it while the people inside dig away. Meanwhile the increasing pressure of the growing tower helps push the chamber, which is called a
伸出水面，让好空气进来，坏空气出去，同时那些微小的人用他们的微小工具敲击，不知为何在你的浴缸底部挖掘。这就是这个想法。你建造一个水密室，找到一种方法让空气在室内循环，然后把它推到底部，开始在它上面建造你的塔，同时里面的人在挖掘。与此同时，不断增长的塔的压力有助于将这个被称为沉箱的腔室推得越来越深。所以如果你要在1870年建造一座横跨东河的桥，如果你要自更新世以来第一次在物理上连接曼哈顿岛和对岸的布鲁克林，
caisson, deeper and deeper into the hole. So if you are going to build a bridge over the East River in 1870, if you are going to physically connect the island of Manhattan with Brooklyn on the opposite shore for the first time since the Pleistocene, if you are going to physically connect the island of Manhattan with Brooklyn on the opposite shore for the first time since the Pleistocene. If you are going to connect the two cities, open up a path for travel and trade and commuters and tourists and stroller pushing park slope parents. You are going to need to build a roadway that is 1600 feet long with cables swooping from stone towers that rise more than 275 feet in the air. And you will need a caisson built of wood and metal,
（续上）如果你要连接这两座城市，开辟一条供旅行、贸易、通勤者、游客和推着婴儿车的公园坡父母使用的道路。你需要建造一条1600英尺长的道路，电缆从高出地面275英尺以上的石塔上垂下。你需要一个用木头和金属建造的沉箱，
a cap-sized ship of a thing. You will need to float it out to the middle of the river and sink it to the bottom, 80 feet down. And then start digging another 44 feet on the Brooklyn side, 78 feet on the Manhattan side, through mud and silt and stone until you hit bedrock. And you will need men to do the work. They were Irishmen, and Italians and Germans mostly. New arrivals, new Americans, who would pile into boats for the first shift on a January morning, or just before dark for the second shift,
一个翻倒的船一样的东西。你需要把它漂浮到河中央，沉到80英尺深的水底。然后开始在布鲁克林一侧再挖44英尺，在曼哈顿一侧挖78英尺，穿过泥浆、淤泥和石头，直到你到达基岩。你需要人来做这项工作。他们大多是爱尔兰人、意大利人和德国人。新移民，新美国人，他们会在一月的一个早晨乘船进行第一班工作，或者在天黑前进行第二班，
or just before midnight for the third, and set out for the construction site, a few hundred feet from shore, where the stone tower was beginning to rise from the water. And they'd step off and out onto the rough boards of the pier, and descend one by one into a hole, into the darkness, a blast of heated air coming up from below, iron rungs beneath their boots, lunch pails clacking against the walls, men below and men above coughing and cursing, cracking jokes in unfamiliar tongues. And then they come to a hatch and turn a wheel and descend into an iron chamber
或者在午夜前进行第三班，出发前往距离岸边几百英尺的施工现场，石塔开始从水中升起。他们会走下码头粗糙的木板，一个接一个地进入洞里，进入黑暗中，一股热气从下面涌上来，靴子下是铁梯，午餐盒撞击着墙壁，下面的人和上面的人在咳嗽和咒骂，用陌生的语言开着玩笑。然后他们来到一个舱口，转动一个轮子，进入一个铁室，
and be sealed within. Down below this chamber, further still on the river bottom, 5,000 pounds of pressure pushed on every square foot of the timber caisson. It would have crushed it and the workers within, except pressurized air was pumped in. It balanced out the forces, get the walls from blowing out and letting the river in, and it kept the men alive. But those men needed to be acclimated first to the conditions they would find below, and so they were sealed into this iron chamber. And in would rush the pressurized air up from a hole in the floor. And with
并被密封在里面。在这个腔室下方，更深处的河底，5000磅的压力压在木制沉箱的每一平方英尺上。它本会压碎它和里面的工人，除非泵入加压空气。它平衡了力量，防止墙壁爆裂让河水涌入，并让工人们活着。但这些人需要先适应他们在下面会发现的环境，所以他们被密封在这个铁室里。加压空气会从地板上的一个洞涌入。随之而来的，
it, the pain. This pressure, this pushing deep in your ears. Starting fast and pushing hard. It would be excruciating. And then it would slowly release. Though sometimes it wouldn't. And you'd be stuck all day with it in your head, even after you'd heard a tapping at the bottom of the metal cell, and the trap door at your feet had opened up, and a man streaked with grime and mud and sweat poked his head up into the chamber and beckoned you down into the caisson, into another world at the bottom of the river, and into the gloaming, and the blue limelight flicker along the walls, rippling in the water that pooled in the mud and the
是痛苦。这种压力，这种在你耳朵深处推挤的感觉。开始得很快，推得很用力。那将是极其痛苦的。然后它会慢慢释放。虽然有时不会。即使在你听到金属舱底的敲击声，脚下的活板门打开，一个满身污垢、泥土和汗水的人探出头来，招手让你进入沉箱，进入河底的另一个世界，进入黄昏，蓝色的石灰光在墙壁上闪烁，在泥泞中汇聚的水中荡漾，
muck between the boards and the planks that crisscrossed the river bottom, that creaked and splintered and sank beneath the feet of the men, two hundred twenty-five at a time, there in the caisson, the roof a few feet above their heads, pine beams sealed together with tar to keep the water out. In the 60,000 pounds of rock, the Brooklyn Tower, from crushing them while they worked, it was hot, 80 degrees at least, even in January, and wet. They'd sweat through their clothes before they'd barely started swinging pick or lifting a shovel, scooping up silt and sediment, chipping away at boulders left there by receding glaciers millennia before, coming upon fossils, ferns and shells, and strange things long gone from
在横跨河底的木板之间，在那些木板下，沉箱里一次有225人，屋顶在他们头顶几英尺处，松木梁用焦油密封以防水。在60,000磅的岩石，布鲁克林塔，压碎他们工作时，那里很热，至少80度，即使在一月，而且很潮湿。他们还没开始挥动镐或举起铲子，衣服就湿透了，铲起淤泥和沉积物，凿开几千年前冰川退缩留下的巨石，发现化石、蕨类植物和贝壳，以及早已从地球上消失的奇怪东西。
the earth. And there was this smell, which was kind of no smell. Something with the pressure in the air and your brain in that atmosphere seemed to trick the nose. Which may have been for the best. What with the sweating men and smoke and the slime and the mud. And no bathrooms. Just a dark corner.
而且有一种气味，那是一种没有气味的气味。空气中的压力和那种大气中的大脑似乎欺骗了鼻子。这可能最好。因为有出汗的人、烟雾、粘液和泥土。而且没有厕所。只有一个黑暗的角落。
Or a bucket. Or this box they had. This contraption where you'd go in a trough, and then every now and then everything inside would get whooshed up with the pneumatic tube and rock at the hundred odd feet to the surface where it would all aspirate in a foul cloud above the river. And your voice wouldn't work right either. Your words would come out thin and high, like girls to their ears, which worked well enough to
或者一个桶。或者这个盒子。这个装置，你走进一个槽里，然后每隔一段时间，里面的所有东西都会被气动管吸走，并以百英尺的速度冲向表面，在那里它们会在河面上形成一团污浊的云。你的声音也不会正常工作。你的话会变得又细又高，像女孩一样，这足以听到金属敲击岩石的无情声响，劳作男人的咕哝和哀叹，在河底挖掘，帮助沉箱沉得越来越深，被不断增长的塔的重量推入地下。
hear the unrelenting clang of metal on rock, the grunts and lamentations of laboring men, digging away at the river bottom, helping the caisson sink deeper and deeper, pushed down into the earth by the ever-growing weight of the ever-growing tower. Some weeks would go by and they barely would have sunk the thing six inches. All that digging, all that drilling, all that chipping, kicking sparks, all those times they had hit a stone and not known what lay below. If it would take you an hour to clear on your own, or if that was just what you and a dozen dudes would be doing for the next week.
几个星期过去了，他们几乎没能把东西沉下六英寸。所有的挖掘，所有的钻探，所有的凿击，踢出的火花，所有他们撞到石头却不知道下面有什么的时候。如果你自己清理需要一个小时，或者这就是你和十几个家伙下周要做的事情。
Or six. Diving down blind into black pools. Feeling around for dropped tools. Eating your lunch from a tin. On a rock. In a box. A hundred feet. More. Below the surface of the East River. Sometimes a big boat, a steamer or freighter would pass by, and the displaced water would push against the sides of the caisson, and the board would snap and water would jet in and the chamber would start to fill, until men with hammers and pitch tar could plug it. Sometimes men would pass out, or cry out at the pain in their ears, and the pressure in
或者六个。盲目地潜入黑色的水池。摸索掉落的工具。在岩石上，在盒子里吃午饭。一百英尺。更多。在东河水面以下。有时一艘大船，汽船或货轮经过，被排开的水会推向沉箱的侧面，木板会断裂，水会喷进来，腔室开始充满水，直到有锤子和沥青的人能堵住它。有时人们会晕倒，或因耳朵的疼痛而尖叫，
their heads or their chests. Sometimes they would rise back to the surface, out from the heat and into the cold, rise up too fast without being properly decompressed, get the bends, get air bubbles, little nitrogen bubbles in their blood, which is as painful as it sounds, and sometimes men wouldn't really recover. One day a fire broke out and it looked like the side of the caisson was going to blow in and the roof cave in and the tower come down and crush everyone inside. But it didn't. And the men came back to work
以及头或胸部的压力。有时他们会回到水面，从高温中出来进入寒冷，上升得太快而没有适当减压，患上减压病，产生气泡，血液中的小氮气泡，这听起来很痛苦，有时人们无法真正恢复。有一天发生了一场火灾，看起来沉箱的侧面要爆裂，屋顶要塌陷，塔要倒塌并压碎里面的人。但它没有。工人们第二天又回来工作了，
the next day. And went down into the hole. Into that alien world. And again the next day. And again. And again. Think of a man who dug. Who swung a pick, who bent to hoist a shovel full of river bottom, who hefted buckets of stone. Think of his shoulders and chest, triceps and lats, like stone. Think of his head on a pillow, packed with straw, in a boarding house at the end of the night. No aspirin, no ibuprofen, or Vicodin, or heating pads. Just pain. Think of those
又下到了洞里。进入那个外星世界。第二天又来了。又一次。又一次。想想一个挖掘的人。谁挥动镐，谁弯腰举起一铲河底泥，谁搬运桶装石头。想想他的肩膀和胸部，肱三头肌和背阔肌，像石头一样。想想他晚上在寄宿处枕头上，塞满稻草的枕头。没有阿司匹林，没有布洛芬，或维柯丁，或加热垫。只有痛苦。想想那些
shoulders and arms and joints within, of bursitis and microtears, fraying tendons, rotator cuffs. No treatment, no insurance. Think of years living in that body after months working in that caisson. And think of a day in 1871 when the man in that body steps up through the hatch and into the air cold on his skin when he knows that the job is done. That he is done with the river bottom for good. There was a parade when they opened the bridge. On a spring day in 1883. A perfect day, they say.
肩膀、手臂和关节，滑囊炎和微撕裂，磨损的肌腱，肩袖。没有治疗，没有保险。想想在沉箱工作几个月后，在那具身体里生活了几年。想想1871年的一天，那个身体里的人穿过舱口，皮肤感受到寒冷的空气，当他知道工作完成了。他永远离开了河底。桥开通时举行了游行。在1883年的一个春日。他们说是一个完美的日子。
Fourteen years after they'd started construction. Fourteen years after the first men had gone down into the Brooklyn caisson. Eight years after the last men climbed out of the one on the Manhattan side, and they'd poured concrete down into the hole and sealed it up. Fifty thousand people came in from out of town. Came in off boats from Connecticut and Massachusetts and Jersey. The president came up from D.C. People sold souvenirs.
在他们开始施工十四年后。在第一批人进入布鲁克林沉箱十四年后。在最后一批人从曼哈顿一侧的沉箱爬出来八年后，他们把混凝土倒进洞里并密封起来。五万人从城外赶来。从康涅狄格州、马萨诸塞州和新泽西州的船上下来。总统从华盛顿赶来。人们兜售纪念品。
Bands played. There was bunting. It was a day for bunting, in little flags in little girls' hands. There were speeches and photographs and fireworks, and a quarter of a million people walking the bridge in its first twenty-four hours, marveling at the thing. This thing they'd watched grow for years, for half their lives, for all their lives, depending. They could now walk from Manhattan to Brooklyn, see those towers up close, see their city from high up, higher off the ground than most of them had ever been, see seagulls and seabirds
乐队演奏。有彩旗。那是挂彩旗的日子，小女孩手里拿着小旗子。有演讲、照片和烟花，二十五万人走过这座桥，在最初的二十四小时内，惊叹于这个东西。这个他们看了几年，半辈子，甚至一辈子，取决于年龄的东西。他们现在可以从曼哈顿走到布鲁克林，近距离观察那些塔，从高处看他们的城市，比他们大多数人曾经离地的高度都要高，看海鸥和海鸟，
and terns turning beneath their feet. 250,000 people. The governor, the mayors, various dignitaries, prominent business owners. A who's who of people no one remembers now. Marveling at the thing. In the river, so far beneath their feet. And with them, somewhere there in the crowd, men who could look down at the river and know just what lay beneath it. I'm sorry. I love that story so much.
还有燕鸥在他们脚下盘旋。25万人。州长、市长、各种政要、杰出的企业主。一个现在没人记得的“名人录”。惊叹于这个东西。在河里，在他们脚下很深的地方。和他们在一起，在人群中的某个地方，有些人可以俯视河流，知道下面到底有什么。对不起。我太喜欢那个故事了。
Just so people know, your book, The Memory Palace, you're making an audiobook of it, and you've asked different people to read the story so that's something new for the audiobook and I'm reading the story, which is one of my favorites, so I'm so happy about that. But one of the things that strikes me reading this story which is one of my favorites so I'm so happy about that. But one of the things that strikes me about hearing it again is that you never say the name Roebling, the civil engineer who designed the Brooklyn Bridge, and you also don't say the name of his wife who was the person who finished it when Roebling couldn't. Could you talk me through that decision?
为了让人们知道，你的书《记忆宫殿》，你正在制作有声书，你请了不同的人来读这个故事，所以这对有声书来说是新的，我正在读这个故事，这是我最喜欢的故事之一，所以我对此感到非常高兴。但阅读这个故事时，我印象深刻的一点是，你从来没有提到罗布林（Roebling）这个名字，那个设计布鲁克林大桥的土木工程师，你也没有提到他妻子的名字，她是罗布林无法完成时完成它的人。你能跟我讲讲这个决定吗？
What's the story that you wanted to tell? This is a story, I mean I could have told a story about Roebling, that story about a dude doing dude things for sure. You know, he's a guy, he's got a wife, he's got a job to do, he gets sick. It's like it's incredible story. It is. Yeah, absolutely. Like it's, if I were if someone ever, you know, asked me to write my Titanic, I would
你想讲的故事是什么？这是一个故事，我的意思是，我本可以讲一个关于罗布林的故事，那个关于一个男人做男人该做的事情的故事，当然可以。你知道，他是一个男人，他有一个妻子，他有一份工作要做，他病了。这就像是一个不可思议的故事。确实是。是的，绝对是。就像，如果有人曾经，你知道，让我写我的《泰坦尼克号》，我会
find some way to write some story about some immigrant kid in Brooklyn, and some beautiful young woman in Manhattan. And somehow they get wrapped up in this in the story about some immigrant kid in Brooklyn and some beautiful young woman in Manhattan and somehow they get wrapped up in the story of the construction of the Brooklyn Bridge. Like, it's an amazing story. But if the Memory Palace is interested in anything, it is that place where real people with real bodies live. And I've seen pictures of the caissons and I've seen Ken Burns' documentary trying to
找到某种方法写一个关于布鲁克林的一个移民孩子，和曼哈顿的一个美丽的年轻女人的故事。不知何故，他们被卷入了这个关于布鲁克林大桥建设的故事中。就像，这是一个了不起的故事。但如果《记忆宫殿》对什么感兴趣，那就是真实的人带着真实的身体生活的地方。我见过沉箱的照片，我见过肯·伯恩斯的纪录片试图
recapture that but I realized that the best way to capture that is in the imagination. To try to place people as best as I can inside a caisson, and not just inside a caisson but inside a caisson and then out again. Like the fact that this is your work, that this is what you need to do. The terror of it is just astounding to me. So somebody is like, let's come back and let's remind people what this is really like.
重现这一点，但我意识到捕捉这一点最好的方法是在想象中。尽可能地把人放在沉箱里，不仅是在沉箱里，而且是在沉箱里，然后又出来。就像这是你的工作，这是你需要做的事情。它的恐怖程度让我感到震惊。所以有人说，让我们回来，提醒人们这到底是什么样的。
But once you start doing that kind of like act of active, empathetic imagination and trying to really put yourself into it, it's like all these other things come out like, oh my God, then they're doing this at a time before like ibuprofen. They are. That they're working this hard with no one paying for their retirement. It really is incredible. And it is when you really dive in, and it's not just put yourself in these shoes, but just try to imagine the human experience as you know it, through the lens of these conditions
但一旦你开始做那种主动的、共情的想象，并试图真正把自己投入其中，就像所有这些其他事情都出来了，比如，天哪，他们是在布洛芬出现之前做这件事的。他们确实是。他们工作得如此努力，却没有人为他们的退休买单。这真的很不可思议。当你真正深入其中时，不仅仅是设身处地，而是试着通过这些条件和那个时代的视角，去想象你所知道的人类体验。
and through the lens of this time. It's one of the most powerful things, I don't mean it's the most powerful thing that I achieve through these stories, because who knows, but it's one of the most powerful things that I simply do. That every couple of weeks when a Memory Palace episode comes out, or I'm sitting down to write a story for this book, for it to work right, it requires me to stop my day and consider these fundamental truths that we will all die one day,
这是最强大的事情之一，我不是说这是我通过这些故事实现的最强大的事情，因为谁知道呢，但这确实是我简单地做的事情之一。每隔几周，当《记忆宫殿》的一集发布时，或者我坐下来为这本书写一个故事时，为了让它正常运作，它要求我停止我的一天，考虑这些基本真理：我们终有一天会死，
that our moment is fleeting, and that other people are other people, and that it's worth thinking about them and it's worth trying to get people to connect in the same way and maybe feel that thing that I've always kind of found personally useful. More stories from the Memory Palace and Nate Dimaio after the break. So we're back talking with Nate Dimaio about his new book, The Memory Palace, and we're featuring a couple of stories from the show today. So Nate, I wanted to play one more piece from the book. And while lots of
我们的时刻是短暂的，其他人是其他人，值得去思考他们，值得去尝试让人们以同样的方式联系起来，也许感受到我一直认为个人有用的那种东西。休息后会有更多来自《记忆宫殿》和内特·德梅奥的故事。所以我们回来继续和内特·德梅奥聊他的新书《记忆宫殿》，我们今天在节目中精选了几个故事。所以内特，我想再播放书中的一个片段。虽然很多
memory palace stories are short, this is the first story in the book and maybe like the shortest of the bunch. So why is it first? And what do you think would be interesting for people to know before they hear it? This is the first story. And it is often one that, like, for instance, if I am writing an email to someone that I want to interview me, and they don't know the show, I might send them this one. Because the truth of matters, I think it does a lot of things that the Memory Palace does.
《记忆宫殿》的故事很短，这是书中的第一个故事，也许是其中最短的一个。所以为什么它是第一个？你认为人们在听到它之前知道什么会很有趣？这是第一个故事。而且它通常是这样的，例如，如果我正在写一封电子邮件给我想采访的人，而他们不知道这个节目，我可能会发给他们这一篇。因为事实是，我认为它做了很多《记忆宫殿》会做的事情。
So why not give someone something that is concentrated and punchy that will tell you what you're in store for? And this story about Samuel Morse. This is a story that really speaks to the concision at all costs thing. Like I love short things. That you know, like, you know, one of the most formative things I ever saw, you know, it was a UFCW hall in Santa Barbara, California. I saw a band called Portraits of the Past, a hardcore band from Santa Cruz, California, play for 11 minutes. And they were amazing. They played like five songs and they were done.
所以为什么不给别人一些集中且有力、能告诉你你会得到什么的东西呢？这个关于塞缪尔·莫尔斯的故事。这是一个真正体现“不惜一切代价追求简洁”的故事。就像我喜欢短的东西。你知道，你知道，我见过的最具形成性的事情之一，你知道，是在加利福尼亚州圣巴巴拉的一个UFCW大厅。我看到一个叫“过去的肖像”（Portraits of the Past）的乐队，一个来自加利福尼亚州圣克鲁斯的硬核乐队，演奏了11分钟。他们太棒了。他们演奏了五首歌，然后就结束了。
And I just realized that not only was, did it have the energy I wanted and the emotionality that I wanted, and all this just like good stuff of youth and wonder. There was just real magic in getting in and getting out. Like how little can I tell someone about this event, but still get them to feel deeply, still get them to be outraged or tearful, or make them want to go hug their kid a little harder. Yeah, totally.
我意识到，它不仅拥有我想要的能量和情感，以及所有这些关于青春和惊奇的好东西。进入并离开确实有一种真正的魔力。我能告诉别人关于这个事件的多少信息，但仍然能让他们感受到深刻，仍然能让他们感到愤怒或流泪，或者让他们想去多拥抱他们的孩子一点？是的，完全正确。
And this story about Samuel Morse definitely does that. So let's hear it and we'll have a little more to say on the other side. Samuel Finley Breece Morse spent the first 35 years of his life learning to paint at Andover at Yale, in London at the Royal Academy. He studied the works of the masters to learn how Michelangelo built bodies that seemed to pulse and shudder out of mere oil and shadow and cross-edge. To learn how Raphael summoned the spark of inner life with a single stroke of pure white
这个关于塞缪尔·莫尔斯的故事绝对做到了这一点。所以让我们听听它，我们在另一边再多说一点。塞缪尔·芬利·布里斯·莫尔斯（Samuel Finley Breece Morse）花了生命的前35年学习绘画，在安多弗，在耶鲁，在伦敦的皇家艺术学院。他研究大师的作品，学习米开朗基罗如何构建那些似乎在纯粹的油彩、阴影和交叉影线中脉动和颤抖的身体。学习拉斐尔如何用单一的纯白色笔触唤起内在生命的火花，
in the dusky ochre of a noblewoman's eye. To learn how to create illusions of space and distance. To learn how to conjure the ineffable through the mere aggregation of lines and dots and stretch canvas. He learned how to paint. And in 1825, Morse was living in New Haven, Connecticut with his wife Lucretia and two young sons. And a third child was on the way, due any day.
在贵妇人眼睛那昏暗的赭色中。学习如何创造空间和距离的幻觉。学习如何通过线条、点和拉伸画布的简单聚合来召唤不可言说的东西。他学会了如何绘画。1825年，莫尔斯和他的妻子卢克丽霞以及两个年幼的儿子住在康涅狄格州的纽黑文。第三个孩子即将出生，随时可能到来。
One night, a courier delivered a message. The city of New York wanted to pay Morse $1,000 to paint a portrait of the Marquis de Lafayette. The hero of the revolution was coming to Washington to celebrate the 50th anniversary of the start of the war, and he would sit for Morse if the painter could leave right away. So he packed his easel and his brushes and his paints, and clothes that were good enough to wear when meeting a man like Lafayette. And he kissed his pregnant wife, and he left that night. On another night, a week later, Morse was in his rented studio in Washington, preparing
一天晚上，一名信使送来了一条消息。纽约市想付给莫尔斯1000美元，让他为拉法耶特侯爵画一幅肖像。这位革命英雄正要来华盛顿庆祝战争开始50周年，如果画家能马上动身，他会为莫尔斯坐下来当模特。所以他收拾好画架、画笔和颜料，以及足以在见到像拉法耶特这样的人时穿的衣服。他吻了吻怀孕的妻子，那天晚上就离开了。一周后的另一个晚上，莫尔斯在华盛顿租来的工作室里，准备
for the arrival the next morning of his distinguished subject. He heard a knock on the door, and there was a courier, breathless and dirty from a hard ride on Hard Road, handing him a note that was five words long. Your dear wife is convalescent. He left that night. He rode for six days straight on horseback and in the backs of juddering wagons, wrapped in blankets against the cold wind of October nights. And when he made it to New Haven
第二天早上迎接他尊贵的模特。他听到敲门声，是一个信使，因为在艰难的道路上骑行而气喘吁吁、满身尘土，递给他一张只有五个字的纸条。你的亲爱的妻子正在康复中。他那天晚上就离开了。他骑马连续六天，在颠簸的马车后座上，裹着毯子抵御十月的冷风。当他到达纽黑文，
and ran through fallen leaves up to the house on Whitney Avenue, he learned that his wife was dead. In fact, she had died before the courier had knocked on his door in Washington. In fact, she had already been buried some morning while he was on the road, while he was racing home to be by her side and sit with her while she got better. Samuel Finley Breece Morse spent the next 45 years of his life trying to make sure no one would have to feel the way he felt that night, ever again. Samuel Finley Breece Morse spent the next 45 years inventing the telegraph to turn real space and real
跑过落叶来到惠特尼大道的房子时，他得知他的妻子已经死了。事实上，在他敲响华盛顿的门之前，她就已经死了。事实上，当他在路上，当他赶回家想陪在她身边，在她好转时照顾她时，她已经在某个早晨被埋葬了。塞缪尔·芬利·布里斯·莫尔斯花了余生45年的时间，试图确保再也没有人会感受到他那天晚上感受到的那种痛苦。塞缪尔·芬利·布里斯·莫尔斯花了余生45年的时间发明了电报，将真实的空间和真实的
distance into illusion in developing Morse code, dots and lines that could transmit the stuff of real lives and of dying wives. I mean you're right. This does, it's heartbreaking. It is a very short story. And there is a kind of surprise reveal, even though it is not a hidden thing you did. You said the name Samuel Morris, but you gave all of his middle names to maybe throw you off a little bit.
距离变成了幻觉，开发了莫尔斯电码，点和线可以传输真实生活和垂死妻子的东西。我的意思是你是对的。这确实，令人心碎。这是一个非常短的故事。而且有一种惊喜的揭示，即使这不是你做的隐藏的事情。你说了塞缪尔·莫尔斯的名字，但你给了他所有的中间名，也许是为了让你稍微偏离一点。
That is the technique. Yeah. So, it's kind of set up as a mystery, even though it's not required to be a mystery for it to be effective. And what you talk about in this story is the feeling of Samuel Morris's grief over the loss of his wife and how that feeling could have propelled the invention of Morse code, which is not the thing most people talk about. Yeah. I think that so much of my work, but so much is just my life in general, feels
这就是技巧。是的。所以，它被设定为一个谜，即使它不需要成为一个谜也能有效。你在故事中谈到的是塞缪尔·莫尔斯对失去妻子的悲痛感，以及这种感觉是如何推动莫尔斯电码的发明的，这不是大多数人谈论的事情。是的。我认为我的很多工作，以及我生活中的很多事情，都感觉
like it is thinking about the gap between history as it's told and life as it's experienced, right? And that is our own stories, right? We once had a bad breakup and we tell the story of that breakup to different audiences for different reasons. And somewhere in the telling is the truth. But what is missing is those, like, days of misery, or those, like, that terrible feeling you have in your stomach
就像是在思考被讲述的历史与被体验的生活之间的差距，对吧？那也是我们自己的故事，对吧？我们曾经经历过糟糕的分手，我们会因为不同的原因向不同的听众讲述那段分手的经历。在讲述的过程中，真相就在某处。但缺失的是那些痛苦的日子，或者那种你胃里翻江倒海的可怕感觉，
when you know, like, something's got to change and it doesn't. I mean, that's where we live, is in those feelings. And so, this is a story that is ultimately kind of about that thing. It's like, here we've created here we've created this code and this technology that allows us to communicate in new ways and ushers in a whole new era and other technologies will be built on it and everyone will be able to do this thing
当你明知有些事情必须改变，却又无法改变的时候。我的意思是，我们就是生活在那些感受之中。所以，这最终是一个关于那种东西的故事。就像我们创造了这种代码和技术，它让我们能够以新的方式进行交流，开启了一个全新的时代，其他技术也将建立在它之上，每个人都将能够做这件事，
and communicate across distances from now on forever. But underlying it is pain, underlying it is art, underlying it is life. That it is art, underlying it is life. That's a quintessential memory palace story because it's like, this is what I think about all the time. Yeah, yeah. So you've done the podcast for 15 years. The book is brand new.
并且从今往后永远能够跨越距离进行交流。但其背后是痛苦，是艺术，是生活。这就是典型的《记忆宫殿》式的故事，因为这就是我一直思考的东西。是的，是的。所以你做这个播客已经15年了。这本书是全新的。
What do you hope people feel when they hear the show or when they pick up the book? What's the goal? What are you trying to reach? Both you know me, but you also know the show. And like, I really am an earnest person. And there is like something about seeing the totality of these people's lives. I just find personally useful.
你希望人们在听节目或拿起书时有什么感受？目标是什么？你想要达到什么目的？你既了解我，也了解这个节目。我确实是一个真诚的人。看到这些人生活的全貌，我个人觉得很有用。
Like I find it like centers me or something and it like keeps me keeps me honest or snaps me into a certain type of like mindfulness for as you know overused as the word is. And in these stories, like I hope a person picks up the book. I hope that they're having a weird day, and I hope that it sparks that little bit of wonder. I hope it brings them back to their present moment and hangs with them in the same way that these things that I discovered once.
我觉得它让我内心平静，或者说它让我保持诚实，或者让我进入某种正念状态，尽管这个词已经被用滥了。在这些故事中，我希望有人拿起这本书。我希望他们那天过得有些奇怪，我希望它能激发那一点点惊奇感。我希望它能把他们带回当下，并像我曾经发现的那些东西一样，与他们产生共鸣。
I hope that my stories are those things, and I hope they hang with them and they want to tell their spouse about them and that they linger in the same way that these really formative experiences did for me. Well, Nate D'Amato, thank you so much for the podcast, Memory Palace. Thank you so much for the book, the Memory Palace. Thank you for inspiring me and talking with me. I really enjoyed it. Literally right back at you on all of those things. You just shove in 99% Invisible, you shove in Roman Mars, and right back at you.
我希望我的故事就是那些东西，我希望它们能留在他们心中，让他们想告诉自己的配偶，并像那些对我而言具有决定性意义的经历一样，久久萦绕在心头。好的，内特·达马托，非常感谢你的播客《记忆宫殿》。非常感谢你的书《记忆宫殿》。谢谢你激励了我并与我交谈。我真的很享受。同样的话我也送给你。你把《99%隐形》和罗曼·马尔斯也算上，同样的话也送给你。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Jason de Leon, edited by Nina Potuck, with additional production help from our intern, Taylor Cedric, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real and George Langford. Kathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Coleson is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube,
本周的《99%隐形》由杰森·德·莱昂制作，尼娜·波图克编辑，实习生泰勒·塞德里克提供额外制作帮助，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，斯旺·里尔和乔治·兰福德配乐。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔森是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁贝，
Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Dawn, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Glathny, Kelly Prime, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, and me, Roman Mars. The 99%onado Medina, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of us below go was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building and beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our brand new discord server
埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·雷、拉什玛·道恩、乔·罗森伯格、加布里埃拉·格拉特尼、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们现在是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心以北六个街区的潘多拉大厦。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，以及我们全新的Discord服务器，
where over 5000 people are talking about the powerker architecture, a bunch of other stuff. There's even podcast recommendations, book recommendations. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那里有超过5000人在讨论建筑、设计以及其他各种事情。甚至还有播客推荐和书籍推荐。那里有相关链接，以及《99%隐形》的所有往期节目，网址是99PI.org。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。